[Music]
I'm Jake
one of 40 finalists here in San
Francisco competing for $100,000 chill
grant it all comes down to a two-minute
pitch and one life-changing decision to
drop out of school and pursue our dreams
this is teen Technorati
I think we've just seen the strongest
class of finalists we've ever had the
time they're going to start changing the
world is today and the people that will
help them change the world is all of you
it's really just beginning I mean what
really happens is after these pictures
is you know when we're at the table
really hands on with the mentors and the
other fellows first no one wanted to
talk and we wondered if our pitches
weren't good enough I've never done
speaking in that scale before so nothing
speaking at all in public like people
think what I'm doing is interesting
they'll come talk to it
once the mentor started asking questions
we realized how serious this competition
really was or anything like that it's
currently exists robotics is doing some
similar thing this one works like it's
like earthquakes also fire and house
rescue and mines
I basically built my own robot which
goes into mines it can climb up stairs
and it sends back video feed until these
HMV classes so you can basically go near
a body or something and measure if they
still alive and that way it's much
easier to find out where they are and
locate them to save them I can get about
five of them and took like talk to each
other and that way you can instead of
being one big one you can like it
sprayed the five of them out and if one
gets stuck then the other one can go
through my dad say taxi business owner
and my mom's to manage our mobile gas
station they're not in computing so I
don't know where I got the technology
aspect of it
I like to build really cool my
company watch send makes analytic
software for people who don't have time
to learn how to use analytic software we
make software for people who make
software I don't know that I have a hero
popular celebrities in technology like
Elon Musk Steve Jobs Bill Gates you sort
of hear caricatures of them my heroes
are everyday people I suppose my
roommates do amazing things and they're
amazing people we've had the opportunity
to sit with some of the finalists one on
one it's a write about it and explain
our thoughts and make recommendations
and you're doing all this myself I have
been getting a lot of community use the
lab space and also access to drugs as
well you are immersed in this deep
subject and this person who's incredibly
passionate about solving something or
making the world better what's the
business plan so right now we'll put
someone on Mars and one of the hundred
days
the mentors didn't go easy on us but in
the end it helped us only more
effectively articulate our project I
know I can make this thing huge it's
always just been such an integral part
of my life what motivates me about this
specific project is that here I was with
an idea and a computer and now I'm like
actually changing people's lives that's
really inspiring to see young people
with big dreams and actually have the
ability to execute
we're just saying how our day when the
levels that I'm blown away I'm really
impressed I'm inspired
now finally done so I could just relax
and catch up on my TV shows
I mean it's Sunday night so it's Game of
Thrones night join us for the next
episode of teen technorati when the big
decisions are made who will be this
year's teal finalists subscribe to the
wired Channel to find
[Music]